[Music]
probably no single American in history
has accumulated more power without being
elected than dr. Tony foutch II most
people never heard of him before months
ago now he runs the country how has he
used that power well often to promote
wild speculation some of it untrue that
has nevertheless taken as gospel by
millions of fearful Americans at one
point foul she told us that coronavirus
was so deadly
we should never shake hands again oops
there goes one of the oldest traditions
known to man but factually also endorsed
breaking lockdowns to have sex with
strangers you meet online okay this week
doctor foul she warned that coronavirus
is so dangerous that the entire NFL
season may have to be canceled Dave
Portnoy I did not vote for Anthony
foutch II he did however found barstool
sports some were happy to have him on
tonight to assess the reign of president
fatty Dave do you think that our
unelected monarch Tony foul Chi is
making the right decision by destroying
America's most popular sport well the
good news is I don't think he has any
actual influence on it and in a rare
situation the only man who thinks he was
elected without being elected by the
American people more than him Roger
Goodell I think he did infect his own
family with Corona before canceling the
NFL season
don't you know I I don't they're gonna
play the NFL why bouchy feels like he is
the right to say they're not he can
certainly say you know maybe dangerous
but the way he phrased it it was like he
was the end-all be-all on that I would
actually be very curious to see if he
tried to you know actually install that
regime first the Roger Goodell regime is
you know all hell would break loose in
that case so I didn't hear a single
thing that you said after you
complimented Roger Goodell cuz I never
thought I would live to hear that was it
was it hard for those words to form on
your tongue well it wasn't exactly a
compliment I did say he would infect his
own family with Corona if it meant you
know they get to play the NFL season so
I Roger Goodell does not care about
safety or anything like that this could
be you know the greatest pandemic of all
time he's playing again why ouchy
thought he had the right to act like he
was the decision-maker I have no idea
what is this gonna do to attendance at
the games you know I I think we're
seeing right now the American people
clearly have Co fed fatigue whether
that's right or wrong people are showing
up in droves to casinos to bars if you
let people go to the game they're gonna
go where the American people humans in
general are social creatures
so they'll show up the only way they
won't is if we physically are told we
can't go not allowed in but if you let
people go they're willing to risk it in
by the way I think that should be each
individual's choice of course so we're
hearing yesterday that as possible
stadiums will take the temperature or
somehow test every person with a ticket
trying to get in what would that look
like do you think those would probably
be the longest lines in the history of
lines I mean that's imagine getting in a
bar when you have a slow bouncer with
your ID imagine them actually taking
every single person test I went to
Michigan it takes an hour and a half to
get into that stadium anyways so in
practicality it sounds alright if you
can do it how you can actually make this
work I mean you're gonna have to get to
the game nine hours early you're gonna
have more problems with people
congregating waiting to get in then
actually being in so one of the effects
of the kovat nineteen lockdowns the
quarantines is that people look very
different from the way they did four
months ago a lot of people have gained
weight you haven't obviously but you
have grown a very very bushy beard are
you gonna keep it well talker I haven't
had a haircut in three and a half months
the results are very mixed I'm having
some of the gentle nature the female
some say they like the curls some don't
my barbershop has not opened yet so I'm
very in between I may let the public
decide again I say public I only care
about the
male gender and let them tell me what
they think about it do you have any
sense from your informal polling on the
question what the reaction is I think
it's about 6040 egg like corona date I
got a brilliant tan I look like I just
got washed into Shore Tom Hanks tile
from castaway
it's a tough boat right now I'm not
gonna lie it can go either way depending
on who you talk to Dave Portnoy talking
to his soccer ball great to see him that
day